you've probably seen this horrifying
video released by a border patrol chief
showing smugglers
dropping young children just three and
five years old
14 feet over a border wall then
abandoning them
in the new mexico desert el paso border
patrol chief
gloria chavez is the one who posted the
video
she joins me now chief thank you for
taking time
tell me when you saw this video what was
your initial reaction and why have you
released it
thank you griffin thank you for covering
this important story you know for us
these are some of the tactics
that we see from smugglers all along the
south southwest border
uh when i first saw the images that were
provided to me by my staff
i could not believe what i was watching
i was horrified i was appalled
to see that young child just drop like
that from a 14 foot barrier
to the ground in an area where is so
rocky
it's so mountainous and so remote and
the child for a few
seconds didn't even move so i was very
worried
until i started seeing her movement then
i see a second child be dropped off that
barrier
and then like a third item be thrown
over that fence and then to see them
just abandon these children there
and run up a hill and run away without
even caring
for the welfare of those children or how
they were on the other side of that
barrier
in chief the cartels obviously behind
this
you want to pursue these two smugglers
but in in terms of sort of the bigger
picture
is this indicative of just how ruthless
these cartels are
it is and i don't think there's like a
doubt in anyone's mind within dhs
i mean i heard the comments of the
secretary the other day so from the
secretary's level of the home of the
department of homeland security
all the way down to the front line
border patrol agent we all know
that these smugglers are very ruthless
they do huge
exploitation of children and families on
this border they take advantage of a
situation
that's vulnerable when it comes to these
human beings and they exploit them for
money
it is inhumane treatment of a human
being and you know griff you've been
along our border in el paso sector
we stretch all the way from fort hancock
texas all the way to new
lordsburg new mexico there are areas
where children are
just walking up to the border crossing
where there is no barrier
so why take these two innocent little
girls
three years and five years old to an
area in new mexico where there is a 14
foot barrier
and drop them from the top of it when
clearly there was another
area where if they were going to push
these little girls into the u.s
side they could have easily walked
through an open area
where there was no need to harm them
that way
that's a great point chief and in your i
believe 264 miles it is rough
terrain and certainly this video is a
very
telling it really captures the brutality
of this crisis let me ask you
to parents because there's the push
factors in the northern triangle of
poverty and violence in
honduras guatemala and el salvador to
parents that would consider
allowing their children to make this
dangerous journey what do you say to
them
so most of my my intent with this video
was to get this
out there through all of you so that the
parents that are actually conducting
this type
of arrangement with criminal
organizations or other people that are
encouraging this
like you said those pull factors to
understand that when they turn over
their children
to people like this these people don't
care about their
well-being they treat these children
like a commodity
and from the moment they turn that child
in from their small village
or town whether it's ecuador whether
it's guatemala or the triangle countries
you know they are already starting the
exploitation starts from that moment
on throughout the entire journey i
wonder
every time when i visited with these two
little girls because i was so concerned
about them
i went the next morning to the central
processing center
where we're holding children currently
today and
i wanted to see them they were so
resilient so talkative
but i was standing there and then i
kneeled down and just wondered as they
were talking to me
what kind of experiences or nightmares
they went through
from ecuador all the way to our border
that we don't even know about
because they were the ones that were
being carried by these
ruthless smugglers with inhumane
treatment of the most vulnerable
population in the world children
chief thank you for taking time we just
have a few seconds left because i did
want to ask you one question about
what we project we have just an
unprecedented number of unaccompanied
children
coming across the border now one report
had as many as a hundred and eighty plus
thousand are you hearing anything on
what we might see
this year so flow in general for
us a grif for the operators on the
border we have an overwhelming situation
and we are continuing to work and use
our technology our border patrol agents
are doing a phenomenal job
so kudos to all of them there are trying
to keep up with the flow
but if we continue in the same track
that we are going today
we are probably going to surpass at
least for the el paso sector
we're going to surpass the numbers from
back in 2019 and if you remember we had
a search situation back then
of people coming across the border and
there was about 182
thousand people that we ended up
apprehending that year
and we're on track to supersede that
el paso border patrol chief gloria
chavez thank you for taking time
and please keep us posted thank you
griff